all right so now I'm gonna write my
solution I remember I'm expecting three
of them right so Zed one he's when K is
equal to now pick a value for me
right okay give me any integer you like
give me a value now I've got one I've
got a lot of choices right I'm gonna
start with a nice easy one understand
zero okay when K equals zero
and partly because I know think about
this right what's going to happen to
this one argument am i can expect right
two times zero plus pi/3 all right so
when I pop this into one art form I've
got one there's the modulus cause oh
yeah market right this is fear okay this
is Theta here so really it's two times
zero PI on three two times zero
okay with that one core zero that looks
familiar right
plus I sine zero what's my number one
good okay confirmed there's the first is
the first ring I was expecting now I can
try other values of K right I can try
other noise okay but think about what it
means to try like what if I said gate
100 or that mean okay
it means every time I go and add on to K
I'm getting a bigger and bigger angle
right so I'm just going round lots and
lots and lots of times now if I just
want the principal argument I just want
the principal argument then I want K
equals zero and I want all the numbers
then I close just to 0 does that make
sense so let's try cake with one this
will give me a man next now you so I go
there's my modulus then I go close off
to pile three is my K because 1 plus I
sine
203 okay cause of to pile three clothes
120 degrees he's got it it's going to be
- aha does that gel with what you were
expecting right
in fact we knew we had to you minus 1/2
minus 1/2 for both of them right when I
tries it three in a second plus I times
and I'm gonna get negative reach me I'm
too positive
I am positive we rented okay you're
after that it's just tiny to something
now at this point here like what I know
what the argument is when K equals to 1
I can already see at this line there's
no point trying candies - or rather even
if you do you're just gonna make more
work for yourself can you see why cake
was teased a lot of good many guys when
you put cake was to you right you'll get
4 pi on 3 4 PI on 3 that's already
outside the principal argument see that
because the principal are you guys from
negative PI to PI so once I've got me
spa they don't immediately say well
forget going in the positive direction I
don't wanna do that anymore I might as
well go in other direction so I can stay
within the principal arguments domain
does that make sense
sir I'm ready three
okay now because cosine is an even
function you're still gonna get - aha
and because sine is an odd function
you're gonna get the opposite this which
were the two answers that you got before
or rather three answers that come before
now that seems like a lot of work right
like going straight to the algebra which
is a much simpler way to go if we were
just dealing with a power of three but
now you're ready to give this guy a girl
right this purse is going to be much
more powerful when we try this